[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان
تتفاعل اخرى البدايه من البيت الابيض في
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن وذلك
ثم امريكيه يابانيه توجت جوله اوروبيه
امريكيه الشماليه لرئيس الوزراء الياباني
طوكيو عقيدتها الدفاعيه قبل السريعه
والى موسكو واشاده من الجيش الروسي بما
اعتبره شجاعه من مجموعه فاجر بعد اعلان
بسط السيطره على بلده سوليدار شرقي
اوكرانيا
والى الامم المتحده واليويورك وجلسه لمجلس
الامن الدولي بدعوه من الولايات المتحده
والبانيا لبحث الاوضاع في اوكرانيا بعد
قرابه 11 شهرا على بدء الحرب
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في تطور الميداني اللافت من الجانب الروسي
منذ نحو سته اشهر موسكو تعلم السيطره على
سوليدير شرقيه اوكرانيا وتشيت بما سمته
شجاعه قوات مجموعه فيفا كيف تقول ان
القتال مستمر
طائره انذار المبكر في رومانيا الثلاثاء
لمراقبه الانشطه الروسيه
على خلفيه مظاهره ضد اردوغان في السوق
العمال الكردستاني وتطالبها باحترام
تعاهداتها لضمان الانضمام الى نيته
للرئيس التركي
بيعه طائرات اف 16 لتركيا شرطه موافقتها
عن انضمام السويد وفنلندا في حلف الاطلسي
في ختام قمه امريكيه يابانيه
باستخدام قدراتها كافه بما في ذلك النوويه
رفضا لاي تغيير الاحاديث القوه في اي مكان
بالعالم والصين تطالب الولايات المتحده
واليابان بالتخلي عن مسمته عقليه الحرب
البارده والتحيز الهادي
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منساتنا
الرقميه كنا نقشنا معكم مطالبه وزير
الخارجيه التركيه مولود شوشو اوغلو السويد
بالالتزام بوعودها حول وجود حزب العمال
الكردستاني والبحث بن علي
وقد قالها ان مما يجسد عدم التزام السويد
بالاتفاق معها جريمه الكراهيه التي نفذت
امس في اشاره الى تعليق مجموعه كرديه
تجسد الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وهما من شانه
ان يعيق مساعي السويد لنقل لنيل موافقه
تركيا على انضمامها
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
انضمامها
وقد جاءت نتيجه التصويت على النحو التاريخ
33% قالوا انها رسول كبيره بينما قال
اربعون بالمائه ان الفرؤساء محدوده في ما
راى 27% انه لا فرصه اط من الانضمام
السويد لنيته في هذه المرحله
هذا سؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على منصتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
تونس عشيه احياء الذكر الثانيه عشر للثوره
اتحاد الشغل يدقون قوس الخطر المعارضه
تتاهب لحج انصارها والرئيس يتمسك بالمضيق
في طريقه
من الرجل
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا الليله الماضيه وقالت الوزاره ان
الخطوه ستسمح بعزل القوات الاوكرانيه في
بخموت وقطع الامدادات عنها ووصفتها بانها
خطوه حاسمه في العمليات العسكريه الجاريه
في اوكرانيا وبعيد الاعلان شهاده القوات
المسلحه الروسيه بمواصفاته شجاعه قوات
المجموعه
من جهتي قال متحدث عسكري اوكراني ان روسيا
لم تسيطر على المدينه وان القتال عنيف ما
زال مستمره مؤكدا ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا
تزال تدافع عن مواقعها في المدينه
وكان وزير الدفاع الوطني قد نفى سيطرت
القوات الروسيه على سوليدار مؤكدا ان
الوضع في المدينه صعب للغايه لكنه تحت
السيطره وبثت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
صورا قالت انها لتصدي قواتها لمحاولات
تسلل روسيه
مؤكده ان جنودها يحافظون على مواقعهم في
المدينه رغم الهجمات الروسيه
هذا وقد نشر مركز الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
وامن المعلومات في وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه مقطع فيديو قال ان جنود
اوكرانيين التقطوه من داخل مدينه سوليدار
اعلن المركز ان المدينه لا تزالوا تحت
السيطره الاوكرانيه وان المعلومات الوارده
عن سيطره القوات الروسيه عليها غير صحيحه
بينما قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي انه حتى وان سقطت في يد الروس لن
يكون لذلك اثر الاستراتيجي في الحرب نفسها
هذا ما يتواصل القذف المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طول نهر الدانبل
في مقاطعه خرسون جنوبيه البلاد وذلك منذ
سحاب الروس من المدينه قبل اكثر من شهر
وبينما يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني سعيه الى
استعاده الضفه الشرقيه من النهر يامر من
تبقى من السكان في محيطه انتهاء المعارك
في اسرع وقت
ممكن
لا يتوقف على طول ضفتين نهر النيبر النهر
الذي كان يوما مصدر جد من سياحي للمدينه
الجنوبيه بات نقطه مشتعله بين الاوكرانيين
والروس فالقوات الروسيه التي سيطرت على
غير سون في بدايه الحرب تقهرت الى الضفه
الشرقيه من النار هذه اخر نقطه استطعنا
الوصول اليها عند احدى ضفاف نهر من الجهه
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه تتواجد في تلك
المنطقه من الضفه الاخرى القصف يتواصل بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه في هذه
الاثناء
يقول الجيش الاوكراني انه يسعى الى اخراج
الروس من اخر معاقلهم على ضفه النار
العدو على الضفه المقابله انه يقصف
عشوائيا الوضع يزداد خطوره لكننا مصرون
على اخضاعه في خرسون
بين مصير الغامض ودوي انفجارات متبادله لا
تهدا
البناء
بات مهجوره لكن اخر حراسه اثر البقاء
وحيدا مع كلبه رغم خطوره الوطن
يعمل يوري على حمايه بعض مستودعات الميناء
مقابل ثلاثه دولارات في اليوم غير ان
شظايا الحرب طالت كثيرا مما يحرسه
لا اعرف اين يمكنني الاختباء لكنني احاول
البقاء على قيد الحياه
من استمرار
مؤمنون بان كل شيء سيعود كما كان لن اغادر
الى اي مكان ولدت هنا وسابقى هنا نؤمن
بجيش هنا بقيه انجلينا برفقه تجارتها
الونه لكنها رفضت المغامره بحياه ابنتها
واحفادها فارسلتهم الى بولندا
حمايت نفسي
يامل
نهر دنبر يعتقدون ان كل خطوه اوكرانيه الى
الامام تبعدهم خطوه الى الخلف لتحميهم من
الخطر
وفي تطور غير مسبوق اعلنا حلف الناتو انه
سيؤيده نشر انظمه طائرات الانذار المبكر
اوكس من المانيا الى رومانيا لمراقبه
النشاط العسكريه الروسي
يبدا النيت في نشر انظمه
في رومانيا لمراقبه النشاط العسكريه
الروسي حسب الحلف في مهمه تستغرق بضعه
اسابيع لم يحدد الحلف عدد الطائرات اي وقت
التي سيتم ارسالها الى رومانيا لكن من
المعروف انه يمتلك اسطولا من 14 طائره
وتجري طائرات ايوبكس بالفعل دوريات
المنتظمه منذ شربات فبراير عام 2022 فوق
الشرقيه اوروبا ومنطقه بحر البلطيق سيتم
نشر الطائرات في قاعده القوات الجويه
الرومانيه بالقرب من بخارست من الطائرات
المتمرزه في المانيا
وسينقل حوالين 180 من الافراد العسكريين
الى القاعده لدعم الطائره
يصل سعر طائره اي واكس الى 70 مليون يورو
وتحتاج طاقه من 17 شخصا لتشغيلها وتحلق
بسرعه 800 كيلو متر في الساعه على ارتفاع
لا يتجاوز 17 كيلو مترا ويبلغ مدى طيرانها
احد عشر الف كيلو متر وزمن تحليقها 10
ساعات متواصله يمكن زياده فتره عملها عن
طريق اعاده تزويدها بالوقود في الجو
طائرات اي واكس قادره على مسح ومراقبه
مناطق تصل الى
310,000 كلم مربع ويمكنها رصد اي اجسام
تطير على ارتفاعات المنخفضه
ومتوسطتان ومرتفعه انظمتها قادره على
التمييز بين الاهداف الصديقه والمعاديه
تعتبر اي واكس نسخه مطوره من طائره بوينغ
707 يتم تجهيزها بردار بعيد المدى لرصد
الاهداف في البر الجو تقوم بمهام القياده
والسيطره واداره المعارك كما تتولى مهام
الاتصالات ورصد الاهداف المعديه
وهو الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ومن كيف
رومان
سكرتير لجنه الامن القومي والدفاع
والاستخبارات في البرلمان الاوكراني والذي
نبدا معه اهلا بك سيد همم
ما اخر المعلومات التي لديكم فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في سوليدار
اخر اخبار
الهدو ان الهيئه العسكريه العليا
الاوكرانيه اعلنت ان هناك معارك قاسيه
واي معلومات عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه خرجت
من سردار هي غير موجوده ولم يتم اعلان
اعلان هذا المعارك مستمر
من سيطره كامله لا اسس له من الصحه
موسكو تقوم باعلانات كثيره
متضاربه لذلك طبعا هذا ليس حقيقي وانا اثق
بالهيئه العسكريه
الاوكرانيه العليا ولقد اعلن رسميا ان
المعارك مستمره وبمجرد الاعلان الرسمي
لاننا خرجنا من هناك سوف نقول هذا ولكن
قبل اي اعلان رسمي لا نستطيع ان نقول تحت
السيطره الروسيه
القيمه الاستراتيجيه لسوليدار هل هل لها
من قيمه في السير الحالي للمعارك
استراتيجيا ليس هناك اي اهميه
بالنسبه لنا هذا موقع نصمت به لانها ارض
اوكرانيه ونحن نحارب لكل الاراضي لاجل
جميع الاراضي الاوكرانيه واذا اتتنا اوامر
ان ندافع عن الجبهات هناك
بالنسبه لروسيا
لان الاهميه الاستراتيجيه للسردار هي انهم
يحتاجوا اي نصر بعد خساره خرسان وخارف
هناك قوات
بانر الذي ياتي ب 60,000 من قواته
ويحاربوا بدل القوات
الروسيه ويحاول ان يحصل على اي ناصر
لروسيا قال الاتحاديه للحفاظ على ماء
وجهها
وهم خسروا
الملايين
في خرصون وفي مختلف المواقع لذلك هم
يحاربون بقوه
والاستراتيجيه المهمه الوحيده بالنسبه لنا
هي انها ارضنا قد يكون سردار هناك اهميه
تكتيكيه لروسيا وكيف تنظرون الى دخول في
المعارك
يا حبيبي
انهم يحاولوا الحصول على اي نصر
ويريد ان يعرض لبوتين اي نصر كاذب انه
يستخدم عشرات الالاف من القوات في سندار
وبخموث ويحاول ان يصل الى
مصر قبل الصيف ولكنهم يحاولوا الحصول على
اي نصر على حساب ارواح قوتهم العسكريه
لذلك
هذه
الموقع هذا الموقع ليس محوريه وليس مهم
وهمم ولكن فعلا ان قوه الاكثر هناك شكرا
لجنه الامن القومي والدفاع والاستخبارات
في البرلمان الوكراني معانا الان من موسكو
والاكسندر
همم الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد ارتمونوف همم رغم النفي
الاوكراني هل ما زالت موسكو متمسكه بان
سوليدار اصبحت الان تحت سيطره القوات
الروسيه
مصره على موقفها انها تسيطر على سندار
لاننا لدينا الكثير من الفيديوهات
المتواجد في الانترنت وبامكانكم همم ان
تحصلوا عليها الجنود والقوات الروسيه
متواجده في مركز المدينه وتحررها من
القوات الاوكرانيات ان عمليه تطهير
المواقع مستمره
والقوات
الاوكرانيه تختبئ في
المخابئ همم والملاج التي تتواجد تحت
الارض انذار تقع على موقع مرتفع واسفلها
هناك ملائكه والاوكانيون
يختبئون هناك وعمليات التطهير همم مستمره
ونقوم بقضاء بالقضاء على اخر قوه اوكرانيا
هناك
في الاخبار في الاشهر الماضيه الان وك هنا
كان طباع بان موسكو تريد ان تدخن هذه
السيطره ان تمت فعلا على سوليدار
الموقف بطريقه اخرى اعتقد ان سليدار احد
القلاع التي يحاول الاوكران الدفاع عنها
ويحاول بدفاع عنها بكل قوه
وهذا يفتح لنا امكانيه ان نحتل
التي نسميه نسميها في روسيا ارتوماك
لان
ضخمه هي الطريق
لاصال ذخيره والمد وسليدار هي موقف موقع
مركز
السكنيه لذلك هذا وكانك دخلت الى مركز
التفاحه
وهذا في مركز خط الدفاع الاوكراني ومن هنا
اهميه هذه المدينه نحن ايضا نهت
كمان نسميه ومارك سكي في جميع هذه المدن
هناك معارك قاسيه والاكرانيون ينسحبون لو
نتوقف قليلا عند مجموعه فاكنر التي شاركت
في ال في المعارك واشاذ بها الجيش فاجنر
كانت دائما موسكو تقول لا علاقه لنا بها
عندما كانت تتحرك في ليبيا او في مواقع
اخرى همم الان تقريبا جاءت لنجده الجيش
الروسي كيف نفسر ذلك
ميكروسوفت انك لست دقيقا في السؤال ليس
هناك من ينقذ الجيش الروسي ان القوات
الروسيه تتواصل اعمالها مع الفاجرنر
هناك
اشخاص
وقوات امريكيه ايضا خاصه تعمل داخل القوات
الامري
في افريقيا ونحن دائما نعرف من هذه القوات
ولا احد ينقذ الجيش الروسي لدينا الكثير
من الفرق
الروسيه ومن احد القوات الروسيه التي تعمل
معنا وهي احد اقوى الفرق شكرا
التطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا ودلالات
نشر النيو طائرات استطلاع في دول الجوار
ستكون محور فقره المتابعه وسنسال ضيفنا
على التاثيرات المحتمله لهذين الموضوعين
على ميزان القوه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارج
ان استهداف انصار حزب العمال الكردستاني
للرئيس التركي في ستوكهولم جريمه كراهيه
السويد دانه الواقعه واعلنت تفهمها لرد
الفعل التركي
غضب تركي في وقت لافته اعتبرت الحكومه
التركيه تعليق بعض انصار حزب العمال
الكردستاني
لرئيس التركي في العاصمه السويديه استهداف
خطيرا يتنافى وفق وزير الخارجيه التركي مع
تعهدات سابقه للسويد في اطار سعيها
للانضمام
[موسيقى]
على ذلك ونحن نطالبهما بان يلتزم بالوعود
التي اتفقنا عليها لا اكثر المنظمه
الارهابيه مستمره بوجودها وفعالياتها هناك
وهذا ظاهر ليس عبر جريمه الكراهيه التي
نفذت بشكل واضح الامس بل عبر الفعاليات
الداعمه للمنظمه الارهابيه وتامين العناصر
لها وجمع الموارد الماليه
تقتضي تدخل الحكومه السويديه التي [__]
سفيرها في انقره والغى رئيس البرلمان
التركي زياره رسميه كانت مقرره لنظيره
السويدي الى العاصمه التركيه ادانت السويد
من جانبها ما شهدته يوم الخميس مظاهره
للاكراد في العاصمه ستوكهولم واكدت
الحكومه تفاهمها لرد الفعل التركي واعتبر
رئيس الوزراء السويدي تصرف المتظاهرين
فعلا مقززه
همم
البارحه كانت لدينا واقعه حيث حاول الناس
وان يعبر عن وجهه نظرهم بشان انضمام
السويد الى حلف شمال الاطلسي بطريقه مقززه
وذلك من خلال تقديم الرئيس اردوغان حيث
بدا وكانه يتعرض للاعدام وهذا سيء بكل
معنى الكلمه
في اجواء حرب اوكرانيا تعطي السويد ومعها
فنلندا اهميه بالغه لانضمامهما لحلف
الناتو ويشترط لهذا الانضمام اجماع اعضاء
الحلف على الموافقه ومنهم تركيا التي قالت
سابقا انها ستقبل بشروط وصفت بالامنيه
تتعلق بنشاط عناصر حزب العمال الكردستاني
في البلدين تدخل واشنطن على الخط هنا
وتنقل صحيفه وليستريت جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان اتمام عمليه بيع طائرات اف 16
لتركيا مشروط بموافقه انقره على انضمام
فنلندا والسويد الى النيدو قبل ايام اكد
رئيس الوزراء السويدي ثقه بلاده في موافقه
تركيا على طلب الانضمام للنيترو لكنه اشار
بالمقابل لعدم القدره على الوفاء بكل ما
طلبه الجانب التركي في اثناء تفائل امين
عام الحلفانيه بانتهاء عمليه انضمام
السويد للحلف هذا العام مبديا تفاهما
للموقف التركي ومشيرا لان تركيا هي اكثر
الدول يعني تعرضا لهجمات ارهابيه
معنا من بروكسل هاري ميدل كول المسؤول
السابق بوحده تخطيط السياسات فيتو ومن
انقره اوزجان الكاتب الصحفي التركيه نبدا
من بروكسيل والسيد هذه نديلكو هل دخلت قصه
انضمام السويد الان الى النيته الى دوامه
من الشروط
نعم نعم
دخلت في هذه الدوامه فان انضمام السويد
الى حلف النيته الان يمكن ان نقول انه
بات اسيره همم اسيره حمله السيد اردوغان
الانتخابيه استاذ اردوغان بعد ان واثق في
مدريد مع السويد وفنلندا على جمله من
الخطوات التي ستتخذها اليوم يجد نفسه في
موقع يمكن من خلال الانستعرض قوته امام
الناخبين من خلال اظهار لنفسي على انه قوي
وصلب في مواقفه تجاه انضمامها ثاني
دولهتين وايضا من خلال السياستين الخارجيه
والداخليه لبلادته
في انقره هل فعلا الصوره بهذا الشكل
همم ايتينغ الصدق ان الوضع ليس همم
سوء الكبير الكما كان عليه ذلك انه في
اليوم الاول الذي
بدات في هذا التظاهرات كان رد فعل تركي
قويا جدا واعتقدنا في البدايه كان لدى
تركيا بعض الشكوك حول النوايا السويد ليله
تركيا تسالت لماذا لم توقف السويد هذه
التظاهرات او الاحتجاجات ولكننا الان بعد
ما فهمنا افعال القادم من رئيس الوزراء
السوريه
ايضا انهم ايضا يشعرون بالاحباط
اندريا
اذاعه هذه الاحتجاجات وما حصل
وبالتالي اعتقد الان
السويت تبدا بالتفاوض
والتحاور مع تركيا حول السبل ايقاف مثل
هذه التظاهرات الارهابيه اعتقد انه في
الايام المقبله مثل
21 من يناير هناك تظاهر اخرى في السويد
تهدف الى الاحتجاج ضد تركيا وتقديم الدعم
لارهابيه
اعتقد ان تركيا ستنتظر
السويديه همم
تحاول ايقافها وبالتالي اذا كنا نوع من
الخطوات تقوم بها الشرطه السويديه
فانا ذلك تركيا مره اخرى ستجري مفاوضات
جيده مع السويد
في الحقيقه
كان ذلك بالنسبه لتركيا كان امر مزعج جدا
ان نشهد مثل هذه الاحتجاجات في عاصمه
السويد
وتسائلت تركيا لماذا السويد كبلد يريد
الانضمام الى نيته لماذا
والاحتجاج عليهم بهذه الطريقه
[موسيقى]
الان دخلنا في جوله اخرى من الشروط وهو ان
الولايات المتحده تقول انها لن تمد تركيا
ببعض الاسلحه الا اذا وافقت على دخول
السويد وفي لندنده همم هل هذه سابقه في
علاقه دول الحلف بينها وبين بعضها البعض
امم دول
يظهروا ان حلفاء
يريدون من تركيا
في اقرب وقت
ممكن لا تنتظره حتى الانتخابات في شهر
يونيو المقبل لهذا السبب نتوقع من
الولايات المتحده
ان يستخدم السياسه
والجزره لجعل تركيا توافق في النهايه على
موافقه في تعطي موافقتها لصالح البلدان
بالنسبه للطائرات
الان نحن من الان وحتى شهر المقبل سنرى
ربما اذا ما راينا ان السيد اردوغان يربط
المساله للانتخابات سننتظر حتى ذلك الحين
لكن اعت تركيا في خادمه خاتمه المطار
ستوافق على انضمامي البلدين للنيترو وفي
الاثناء سيدنا النبي تعتقد ان المساله
مساله بيع اف 16 ستظل معلقه حتى موعد
يونيو حزيران المقبل
وان الامر قد يبقى معلقا حتى شهر يونيو
لان السيد اردوغان حقيقه انه يجعل من
بلدين اوروبيين ثريين ان يستطيع ان
يحركهما لصالحه هذا سيكون لمصلحته مع
الناخبين وسيكون صعبه للسيد اردوغان ان
يغير مساره هكذا لكن مع ذلك اعتقد اننا
نتحدث عن اشهر وفي غضون هذه الاشهر صداره
تركيا مختلفه تماما بعد شهر يوليو المقبل
سيد نكت هل هناك انطباع بان لي ضغوط تركيا
في هذا الموضوع حدود اذا تجاوزتها ربما
تنقلب الامور ضدها
التركي
بان موضوع الطائرات اف 16 موضوع مختلف
ومشاركه السويد الانضمام السويد الى
الناتو موضوع مختلف تماما ولكن عندما
تتحدث تركيا مع السويد حول كونها ضد
الارهاب فان تركيا ايضا تخاطب الامم
المتحده الولايات المتحده عفوا بانها
بانها ضد الارهاب الذي يستهدف حلفائها ذلك
المتحده تدعم
الفكر حمايه الشعب الكردي في سوريا فلماذا
لا يتوقفون عن دعم هذه المجموعات
الارهابيه همم
ليس فقط انما الى الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي يعتقد الموضوع تاجيل
تتحول للطائرات اف 16 الى ما بعد انتخابات
هذا امر مفهوم لانه يعتقد انه لما بعد
الانتخابات تتخيل تغيرت حكومه في تركيا
فان هذه الامور سيكون اسهل لها اعتقد ان
مثل هذه النوع من السياسات ليس لا تؤدي
الى اي نتائج ايجابيه لانه حتى بعد
الانتخابات تركيا لن تتغير مصالح التركيه
لن تتغير
الان ان مصالح تركيا
[موسيقى]
الان مباشره الى واشنطن وهذه الكلمه لرئيس
الوزراء الياباني
تلك البلدان التي لا تمتلك رؤيه واضحه
كذلك
ان نكون اكثر التزاما
بقيامنا وفي ذات الوقت اذا ما اردنا ان
ننخرط مع الجنوب يجب ان نتحلى بالتواضع
واننا
جانبا
بهذه التعصبات
ونحترمه
التقاليد
التاريخيه الثقافيه
وايضا ان همم
المجتمع الدولي
يجب ان القاده ليس بالقوه وانما بالقيم
وفي المبادئ وايضا قضيه التعاون في مجالات
مثل الطاقه والصحه
والغذاء يجب ان نتعامل معها من خلال
الجهود مشتركه وايضا ان كل هذه الامور
ستكون الضروريه لخلق نظام دوليا جديد
وطبعا انا ومنذ ان توليتم منصب رئيس
الوزراء اقدمته على خطوات تتعلق به علاقات
اليابان مع الجنوب
وحتى لو شعرنا بان
الذنوب له همم موقع همم جزء لا يتجزا من
مسرح الاحداث الدولي انسحب عن هذه الاحداث
اننا سنطرق اننا لن نكون قادرين على حل
المشكلات التي تواجهنا جميعا ومن بين هذه
اذا كان هذا جانبا من الكلمه التي يلقيها
رئيس الوزراء الياباني في موبيدا في
واشنطن في زيارته التي التقى فيها الرئيس
الامريكي جوبا ايضا وقد اكد بايدا التزام
بلاده بالدفاع عن اليابان باستخدام كل
قدراتها بما في ذلك النوويه وذكر بيان
الامريكيون ياباني مشترك اقبل القمه التي
جمعت الرئيس بيضا برئيس الوزراء الياباني
في البيت الابيض ذكر ان تحالف البلديه
سيبقى حجره زاويه لحفظ الامن والسلامه في
المحيطين الهندي
واضاف البيان ان الجانبين اكد التزامهما
باخلاء شبه الجزيره الكوريه من الاسلحه
النوويه وفقا لقرارات مجلس الامن الدولي
ورفضهما تغير الوضع القائم بالقوه او
بالاكراه في اي مكان من العالم كما اعلن
التزامهما بمواصله فرض عقوبات على روسيا
وتقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا
في المقابل انتقدت الخارجيه السينيه
تصريحات واشنطن وتوكيو التي تقول ان الصين
هي التحدي الاستراتيجي الاكبر في المنطقه
ودعي المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
كلا من الولايات المتحده واليابان الى
التخلي عما سماها عقليه الحرب البارده
واليابان على التخلي عن عقليه الحرب
البارده والتحيز الايديولوجيه والتوقف عن
خلق اعداء وهميين والتوقف عن ادخال عقليه
الحرب البارده في منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ والا تعمل تيار المعاكس لزعزعه
الاستقرار في المنطقه
القمه الامريكيه اليابانيه تاتي بعد
اسابيع من مراجعه اليابان عقيدتها
العسكريه تطورا طرح سؤالا عن مدى التغيير
الذي طرا على سياسه الخارجيه اليابانيه في
مرحله ما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
خصوصا في المجال العسكري والتحالفات
الاستراتيجيه
لم يكن متخيلا ان اليابان ستترك القتال
يوما كان ذلك عندما ضربت قوتها من ابر
الهابر الامريكي اما 41 من القرن الماضي
تلقت اليابان ضربه موجعه من الولايات
المتحده ثم هزمت في الحرب فتحول وجه
اليابان الخارجي
الماده التاسعه للدستور التي تحرم على
البلاد امتلاك اسلحه هجوميه ركزت اليابان
على الاقتصاد التكنولوجي وحافظت على
علاقات بعيده عن التوتر مع دول الجوار حتى
جاءت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ازداد التوتر
في العالم عادت مرحله الاستقطابات
السياسيه والعسكريه دخلت اليابان في الحلف
الغربي وشاركت في العقوبات على روسيا
75 عاما غابت التعزيزات العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه عن اليابان امتنعت عن امتلاك
اسلحه الهجوميه كم امتنعت عن تطوير اسلحه
النوويه اواخر العام الماضي اقرت الحكومه
اليابانيه تعديلات هي الاكبر من نوعها على
استراتيجيه الدفاع ضمن الاستراتيجيه
الجديده القدره على شان هجوم مضاد ورفع
مستوى الصواريخ ووضع القوات البريه
والبحريه والجويه تحت قياده عسكريه موحده
رغم الحفاظ على علاقات متوازنه مع دول
الجوار خصوصا الصين وكوريا الشماليه
وروسيا خلال العقود الماضيه تحول وجه
اليابان اغتصبوا وثيقه السياسه الدفاعيه
الجديده الجاره الصين بالتحدي الاستراتيجي
غير المسبوق وروسيا بمصدر قلق للامن
القومي الياباني هنا تفتح طوكيو اعينها
على الخوف القادم من الغرب
تطلق كوريا الشماليه صواريخ باليستيا تعبر
الاجواء اليابانيه تعتبر اليابان ذلك
تهديدا وشيكا للمنطقه والعالم في الفتره
نفسها تعلن روسيا نشر انظمه دفاع صاروخيه
على سواحلها الشرقيه تراقب اليابان وفق
مجلس الوزراء ويقلقها اكثر تزامن ذلك مع
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تبقى الصين اكثر
الجيران اثاره للرعب 90% من اليابانيين
انه يجب الاستعداد لغزو صيني لتاون
يعتقدها هؤلاء ان بلادهم ستكون الخطوه
التاليه للصين من كل هذه التخوفات انعطفت
اليابان نحو مزيد من التعزيزات العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه تعلن عن اتفاقيه الدفاع
المشتركا مع بريطانيا تتزامن معها رغبه
كنديه يابانيه في تعزيز التعاون الامريكي
الاتفاقيه مع بريطانيا تسمح للبلدين باشرق
قواتنا على الاراضي كل منهما رغم وجود
قرابه 50,000 جندي على الاراضي اليابانيه
فان الاتفاق الجديد مع بريطانيا ينوع
الاعتماد العسكريه اليابانيه الخارجيه لا
تعارض واشنطن بل ترى ان الطوكيو تمثل راس
الحربه في مواجهه تهديدات الصين وكوريا
الشماليه هكذا تحول وجه اليابان الخارجي
نامت مخالبها ضمن التحالف بعيد يستعد كما
يقول لمواجهه مخاطر التحالف هو الاقرب في
الجغرافيا
معنا من لندن جيهان استاذ الدراسات
الصينيه والدوليه في جماعه لا يستر اهلا
وسهلا بك هذا الوجه الجديد لليابان ما
الذي سيغير
يو
اسينجيره هو
موقف
اليابان والعسكري والدولي وفي السابق كانت
قد تعززت قيادتها
ومواقفها وبعض السياسيين الياباني كان
يدعون الى زياده القوه العسكريه ولكن ما
حصل يحصل الان هو يعتبر تغيير في سياسه
يابانيه الداخليه
وايضا بدعم من واشنطن وبالتالي
وهذا يعني
اصبحت فيه وضع جديد في الماضي اليابان
كانت تركز اكثر على القوه الاقتصاديه
وكانت تحاول ان تركز على على التاثيرات
الاقتصاديه والماليه ولكن الان بدا ان
هناك تغيير
لان ماتش ان القوه العسكريه هي نفس نفس
اهميه القوه الاقتصاديه همم الماليه ولكن
هل هل يمكن لليابان ان تطمئن في مواجهه
عملاق مثل الصين بحلفاء مثل الولايات
المتحده او اليابان او استراليا وهم
بعيدون عنها جغرافيه
ان الامان
هو كلها طبعا افتراضيه ما سيحصل الان هو
ان استيقظ استلم الرساله
وبالتالي همم هناك حاجه اساسيه همم
واذا شعرت الصين بانها همم غير امنه قد
تزيد التعاونها مع كره الشماليه ومع روسيا
وهذا في دوري ايضا قد يؤثر على الاستقرار
الاقليمي ويجعل اليابان تشعر اقل امنا
وبالتالي اعتقد نعم بالطريقه اليابان
والتعاونها الوثيقه المتحده
الدفاعيه قد قد يعزز القوه العسكريه ايضا
سيؤدي الى افعال من قبل الصين وان اليابان
لم تتصل بالضروره على ما تحصل تريده اذن
الصعب ان نعرف بالضبط كيف سيكون الرتب الى
الصين وكيف تتعامل معاها كوريا الشماليه
وروسيا لتعامل مع هذا الوضع الجديد شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]
سياسيون في تونس عشيه احياء ذكرى ال 12
للثوره واحتجاجات مرتبه لانصار المعارضه
يقول الامين العام المساعد الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل حفيظ ان الرئيس قيس سعيد
صقر قانون الانتخابيه على مقاسه يكرس
النزعه القبليه والفئويه لانه الغى
الاحزاب والقوائم حسب قوله وعبر حفيظ عن
تاجيل النظر في ملف تونس لدى صندوق النقد
الدولي بسبب ضبابيه المشهد السياسي في
البلاد مضيفا ان افضل الملف ستكون له
عواقب وخيمه على تونس في شتى المجله
وقد اعتبر الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان
بلاده في حاله حرب مع الفساد ومع من وصفهم
بالونه والعملاء داعيا خلال اجتماعيه
باعضاء اللجنه الوطنيه للصلح الجزائي الى
اعاده الاموال المنهوبه الى الشعب ومحاسبه
كل من اذنب في حق التونسيين وفق تعبيره
ضد الخونه
وباسترجع خاصه ببعض العائله
الشركات الاهليه
ونتحول الان الى نيويورك حيث يعقد مجلس
الامن الدولي جلسه بشان تطورات الوضع في
اوكرانيا
حسنه من قبل الطرفين
بحسب روح ومبادئ ومقاصد ميثاق الامم
المتحده
للعمل الانساني بحسب قواعد القانون
الانساني الدولي
وممارسات الانسانيه
السيد الرئيس
واهميه تعزيز
المنصه التي ادت الى مبادره البحر الاسود
الى حد الان
نعم محمد في الواقع سمعنا الى احاطه من
وكيله الامين العام للشؤون السياسيه
روزماري دي كارلو ثم كلمات البانيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واكوادور
وحاليا تتحدث موزمبيق
وبتابعه الحال هناك خمسه اعضاء الجدد الان
في مجلس الامن الدولي همم الى جانب
الاكوادور وموزمبيق هناك ايضا اليابان
وسويسرا ومالطا وجميع هذه الدول باستثناء
موزمبيق تتمنى موقفا في الواقع مدين للحرب
في اوكرانيا ومدين للموقف الروسي باستثناء
موزمبيق التي تحفظت في جميع القرارات التي
همم سويت عليها في همم الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده وهي بذلك تكون تخلف الهند
التي غادرت المجلس وكانت تتمنى موقفا ااه
همم اقرب الى الحياد مع دعوتها بتابعه
الحال الاحترام سياده وحده اراضي همم
اوكرانيا في المجمل صوره قاتمه قدمتها لك
في احاطتها ان على الجانب الامني همم من
حيث اجداد وتيره المعارك شرق اوكرانيه او
حمل حمله القصف الصاروقي وبالمسيرات ولا
سيما على البناء التحتيه المدنيه اشارت
الى ان هناك همم اكثر من 18,000 ضحيه من
المدنيين منذ بدايه الحرب اكثر من 7000 من
بينهم من القتل هناك قرابه 14 مليون من
النازحين واللاجين اشارت الى صعوبه تواجه
عمليات ايصال المساعده الانسانيه في مناطق
شرق همم اوكرانيه وفي المناطق التي تخضع
للصيطره الروسيه اشاره الى انتهاك تتعلق
بحقوق الانسان انتهاكات من قبيله للعنف
والتعذيب والعنف الجنسي واش لان الامم
المتحده ترصد هذه الانتهاكات ايضا ترصد
الاضرار
والاحتياجات التي يتعلق باعاده البناء في
همم اوكرانيا بطبيعه الحال كانت هناك كلمه
للمندوب الامراه الامريكيه وكان القران
تحضيرها من استمرار ايران وكوريا الشماليه
بتزويد روسيا بالصواريخ والمسيرات محمد
شكرا لك مراد هاشم من نيويورك
[موسيقى]
ونواصل الحديث عن حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وتداعياته نعود الى التطورات العسكريه حيث
تسود حاله من الغموض الميداني مع اعلاني
موسكو بسطه السيطره على بلده سوليدار في
الشرق الاكراني فيما تنسى كيف ذلك تقع هذه
البلده على بعد 15 كيلو مترا الى جنوب
غربي ضخمه
وتسعى القوات الروسيه للسيطره عليها منذ
اشهر تقول روسيا ان السيطره على سوليدار
ستمكينها من قطع طرق الامدادات الاوكرانيه
الى مدينه بخمود القريبه والاكبر حجما
تضمه ملح ضخمه بينما ضخمات الاكبر من
سوليدار بعشر مرات هي مركز اقليمي ضخم
تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انه امكنه
السيطره على سوليدار بفضل هجمات الطيران
الحربي والصواريخ والمدفعيه لم تشهد مواقع
خطوط المواجهه الاماميه في اوكرانيا اي
يذكر منذ اخره تراجع كبير لروسيا جنوبا
قبل نحو شهرين
ووسط تصاعد المعارك حول بخموت وسوليدار
اعلن حلف شمال الاطلسي اليوم نشر طائرات
نظام التحذير والمراقبه المحمول جوا
المعروف باسم او واتس نشره في رومانيا
اعتبارا من الثلاثاء لمراقبه الانشطه
العسكريه الروسيه
لم يحدد الناتو عدد الطائرات اواكس التي
سترسل الى رومانيا لكن بحسبه تقارير
اعلاميه فان هناك 14 طائره من هذا الطراز
موجوده في المانيا وسترسل ثلاث منها الى
رومانيا تعمل قواتس على ارتفاع لا يتجاوز
17 كم من مستوى سطح الارض ويصدر رادارها
موجات
كهرومغناطيسيه تستطيع مسحها ومراقبه مساحه
واسعه تتجاوز 300,000 كم مربع ورصد اي
اهداف عليها
يمكن لطائرات خلال تحليقها رصد اي اجساما
تطير على ارتفاعات منخفضه والطائرات
المحلقه على ارتفاعات المتوسطه ومرتفعه
فضلا عن امكانيه تزودها بالوقود في الجو
وقدرتها على التمييز بين الاهداف الصديقه
والمعاديه
تتكون طائره المراقبه والانذار المبكر من
جسم لطائره بوينغ 707 يعلوه رادار اسود
دوار على شكل عش غراب غراب عفوا قطره تسعه
امتار يطلق الخبراء العسكريون اسم العين
الطائره على الهواكس التي يستخدمها حلف
شمال الاطلسي في عملياته العسكريه معنا من
لندن الدكتور فرانك
الخبير العسكري والضابط السابق في
المخابرات العسكريه البريطانيه البريطانيه
اهلا وسهلا بك
دخول طائرات الاواكس اذا سلمنا انها ستدخل
بدايه من الثلاثاء المقبل في رومانيا ما
الذي ستيفه
اثنين
اولا
النظام
الانذار المبكر يوفر لحلف النايته
احتمالات اداء في الخاصه في الجو ان يتوقع
ويعرف ماذا يحدث من احداث في اوكرانيا
في
فيتو وهناك ثلاثه منها ستصل الى رومانيا
من المفروض ان توفر هذه الطائرات القدره
على المراقبه الجويه على مدار الساعه طبعا
هذا الطائرات سبق لها وان نصرت غربه وشرق
الاوكراني لكن لم تكن همم تحطه في
المطارات الرومانيه الان
انطلاقها من هذه المطارد في رومانيا
سيعطيها كفاءه اكثر من ذي قبل لكنه لا
يغيروا حقيقه انها كانت تحلق في سماء
المعركه او بمحاذاه المعركه منذ بدء الحرب
ولكن هل هل يمكن ان تغير سير المعارك في
فتره قريبه وجيزه
حقيقه
فهي من موجوده منذ فتره لا يستهان بها من
الزمن لكن ما تضرنه عليه هذا الخطوه ان
حلف النيته منخرط بشكل كامل على الاقل في
المجال الاستخبارات من وجهه نظريته هذا هم
يحتاجون بحكم الضروره الى المراقبه
الاحداث من وجهه نظر واشنط تقديم اماكن
نشر هذه الطائرات قد ينظر اليها انها قد
لا تكون خطوه عزائيه لكنها على الاقل ليست
دفاعيه واعتقد ان هناك اهميه ما هو مغزى
في هذه الخطوه ولكن هل هذا يمكن ان يستفز
روسيا
وتكون لها همم طريقه للرد بشكل او باخر
افرش
ترد علي
على نشر طائرات استخباريه
لفعلوا ذلك من قبل لكن
طالما ان هذه الطائره
بروسيا الى تحديها وربما بشكل مباشر او عن
طريق الخطا لكن هذه الطائرات لا تعمل
لوحدها هي دائما ترافق بطائرات مقاتله
لحمايتها وفي الحقيقه الدور الاساسي هنا
في المعارك سيكون
لطائرات المقاتل اذن عندما تكون هناك
طائرات مقاتله حوالين ميدان المعركه هذا
واضح انه قد في عين روسيا كاسترزاز لكن
انهم هم ان لم يستجيبوا بشكل ما حتى الان
بعد مرور هذه الاشهر اعتقد انهم شكرا نشر
هذه القوات الهذا الطائرات وهناك دائما
خطوره
الدكتور
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
تحذير لافته قبل انتصاف الشهر الاول من
هذا العام الجديد
2023 قد يشهدوا توترات اجتماعيه على
المستوى العالمي بسبب التباط والاقتصادي
التحديد جاء هذه المره على لسان المدير
العام لصندوق النقد الدولي كريستالينا
جورجيبا التي اشارت الى مشاهد الغضب
الشعبي في البرازيل فاروق بوليفيا
كولومبيا والمملكه المتحده باعتبارها
نماذج لتصاعد التوتر الاجتماعي ما يعني
منطقه اكثر هو تحذير المسؤول الدوليه من
صعوبات كبيره بالنسبه لسكان بلدان ذات
مديونيه مرتفعه وتتراجعوا فيها قيمته
عملتها المحليه الامل كل الامل هو ان
تتكاثف الاطراف المعنيه سواء على مستويات
الوطنيه او الدوليه حتى يمر هذا العام
الحالي بسلام على الجميع دمتم بخير
[موسيقى]